this video was made possible by
Squarespace build your website for 10%
off as Squarespace calm / Wendover the
richest country in the world is Qatar
which looks like this the second richest
country is Luxembourg which looks like
this the third richest is Singapore
which looks like this the commonality
between these three is that each of them
has more than 90 percent of their
population living in cities the three
poorest countries the Central African
Republic the Democratic Republic of the
Congo and Burundi each have urbanization
levels below 50 percent comparing the
wealth of African countries and the
urbanization levels of African countries
the maps are nearly identical that is
not to say that cities automatically
create wealth or wealth automatically
creates cities but there is a direct
correlation between the two although it
seems strange that humans would choose
to live in cities living costs are
higher air quality is worse surroundings
are more crowded crime is more prevalent
and disease is more easily spread if the
population of the world spread itself
out evenly every single person would
have 5 acres to live on but we don't we
live in a world where half the
population lives on just 1 percent of
the land 54 percent of the world
population now lives in cities and
that's significant 55 years ago only
half that lived a city life the
urbanization of the world is changing
the world but why do cities even exist
humans were originally hunter-gatherers
they scavenge for food and often didn't
live in a set place similar to how
animals live but then in 10,000 BC we
learned to farm the domestication of
plants allowed humans to finally settle
down in one singular place and establish
a long-term home but farming was nothing
like it is today the humans of the era
lacked technology and expertise the
first archaeological evidence of
ploughed fields a process that greatly
improves crop yields doesn't appear
until about 3000 BC it took thousands
more years for farmers to successfully
domesticate animals like the Ox to pull
a plow when humans first began farming
nearly every individual had to farm
order to make enough food to live one
person's work essentially produced one
person's food but through time as
technological advancements occurred
progressively each individual was able
to make more and more food
thanks to that farmers today each feed
one hundred and fifty five people the
process has also become so efficient
that only one acre of land is now needed
to feed one person but back in the early
days of farming whence technology had
advanced to the point where one person
made more than one person's food for the
first time ever there were some people
who didn't need to farm and that fact
changed humanity if that had never
happened we would all still be living in
ancient history the surplus of food and
the development of cities really went
hand in hand it had never before been
possible for humans to live in dense
urban conglomerations because they
needed land to farm but these extra
people freed from farming were able to
work jobs other than farming which led
to languages literature science and
really all the technological
advancements that made our modern world
the spatial patterns of humans really
happen quite naturally enough people are
each making their decision on where to
live that in aggregate humans are going
to live in the best places to live
there's a sort of process of natural
selection that happens as billions of
humans each pick their optimal place to
live
nothing is manufactured about where
people live and numbers back this up
you see cities tend to stay at the same
rank throughout history in 1800 the
largest city in Europe was London today
the largest city in Europe is still
London in 1800 the second largest city
in Europe was Paris and it too remains
second today cities grow but those that
were large in the past tend to stay
large at least without external
influence cities don't just change
ranking on their own they change rank if
something else changes Hong Kong for
example change drink when a change in
sovereignty to British drew people in
while with San Francisco the discovery
of natural resources particularly gold
increased growth rates while with
Washington DC the coming of a new
industry the US government changed
the rank if you were to put a pause on
all activity but humans moving rankings
would hypothetically stay exactly the
same but that's not even the best
evidence for how natural the existence
of cities is according to the US Census
Bureau the largest city in the u.s. is
New York with 8.5 million urban
residents then the second is Los Angeles
with 4 million roughly half as many as
New York then third is Chicago with 2.7
million roughly a third and Houston at
2.3 roughly a fourth than Phoenix at 1.6
million roughly a fifth each city size
is almost exactly determined by the
largest cities size divided by a Trank
it is uncanny how closely City sizes in
countries follow this distribution it's
not just with the US Germany's largest
city Berlin has 3.5 million residents
then Hamburg has 1.8 million almost
exactly half and Munich has slightly
more than a third at 1.4 million then
cologne has just a bit more than a
fourth at 1 million then Frankfurt has
almost exactly a fifth at 700,000 now
there are anomalies mostly countries
with a recent rapid population growth
but in a large number of countries the
ranking of cities can be determined by
this law but what's significant is what
else can be determined with this law if
you take a book and rank the frequency
of words it follows this distribution if
you take a stadium of people and rank
them by income it follows this
distribution if you take the sounds a
dolphin makes and rank them by frequency
it too follows this distribution the
link between a distribution found in
nature and the size of cities helps
prove something cities are natural
humans will given time and technological
advancement always form into cities the
existence of cities can really only
happen when the pluses outweigh the
minuses back before the food surplus
there were few advantages to urbanized
living and a huge disadvantage a commute
to farming land during a time when
walking was for most the only
transportation method today the pluses
have increased and keep increasing to
the point where day by day more and more
people live in cities a major advantage
for the existence of cities is the
ability for different businesses to low
near each other part of the reason this
is advantageous is that people come to
cities to find jobs because all these
businesses are there and so if
businesses want to hire the best people
to be the best they have to be in cities
it's a bit of a chicken and the egg
problem but nowadays different cities
tend to play host to different clusters
of businesses for example LA is a hub
for the entertainment industry Boston is
a hub for medical research Dusseldorf is
a hub for the telecommunications
industry and Singapore is a hub for the
finance industry in addition to the
ability to tap into a common labor pool
businesses cluster because they want
easy access to other businesses
telecommunications companies like
Vodafone Deutsche Telekom and AT&T all
exist as direct competitors in
Dusseldorf but the reason they are there
is because other companies exist there
as well that they can work with also in
Dusseldorf for companies like Nokia
Google and LG which each make the phones
that the mobile service providers might
stock in their stores by all being in
the same place they can more easily
collaborate and therefore they can run
their businesses more efficiently
there's a sort of economies of scale
effect when all sorts of companies are
all packed together in one place now not
every business is in a city because
there are plenty of cases where the
minuses outweigh the plusses you just
won't see a car manufacturing plant in
downtown Manhattan because it doesn't
make sense while there would be
advantages such as access to a higher
skilled labour pool proximity to other
businesses and reduced transport costs
by being closer to the final market
there are significant disadvantages land
costs about $38 per square foot in New
York so if Tesla for example wanted to
move their factory to the city it would
cost over 200 million dollars in land
alone the benefits would never outweigh
the costs and in fact it was this very
problem that led to the decline of
Detroit the city was a major center of
automobile manufacturing but eventually
manufacturers figured out that they
could greatly reduce cost by moving the
plants out of the city without a major
industry to employ individuals many
moved away and the population has
steadily declined for the last few
decades cities exist because they are
efficient nobody's forcing individuals
to move to cities but billions have
just imagine there were only ten people
in existence and one product that each
of them wanted to buy if they were all
equally spread out across this plane the
logical location for a distribution hub
would be right in the center some
individuals would happen to be close to
the hub by chance but overall the
product would have to be shipped a large
distance to get to every consumer now
let's say that eight of those ten
individuals lived together in a mini
city the logical location for the
distribution hub would then be right by
the city shipping for the rural
individuals would be slow and expensive
but overall the total shipping distance
and cost to individuals would be lower
you can see this concept with where
Amazon puts their warehouses in the UK
they could have one enormous warehouse
at the geographic center of the country
and save money through economies of
scale but they don't they position each
of their warehouses near major
population centers to reduce the total
shipping distance in our modern context
this concept is most easily demonstrated
through shipping but historically
individuals had to purchase nearly all
their goods at physical marketplaces
even just 200 years ago walking was the
primary means of transportation in an
hour nowadays we can drive 70 miles on
an hour 200 years ago individuals could
walk only three miles so the push to
live closer to marketplaces was even
higher this is why suburbanization is a
new concept but still more individuals
than ever choose to live in cities
division and specialization of Labor was
crucial to the development of our world
imagine you made everything you used you
grew your food you gathered and filtered
your water you built your own car just
imagine how long it would take you to
build a car from scratch at least a
decade and yet the average individual in
the US can buy a brand new car from the
money that they earn in about six months
that's because there are people better
at making cars than you there are some
people who focus solely on mining iron
and then some individuals who focused
solely on making glass and so there are
thousands of people producing all the
different inputs that go into making
your car in the most efficient way
possible let's say that you for example
individually can make a pencil in 60
minutes and paper in 30 while another
individual can make a pencil in 30 mm
and paper in 60 in a closed-off world it
would take each of you 90 minutes to
make a pencil and paper but let's say
you make two pieces of paper which would
take you an hour and the other
individual would make two pencils which
would take them an hour and then you
each trade neither of you have given up
anything you get exactly what you would
have gotten by working independently but
you of each gained time this is exactly
why trade is beneficial certain people
are better at making certain things so
by everyone specializing in what they
are good at the entire world gets more
without giving more cities make this
trade easier which leads to more of it
happening and therefore cities are
efficient humans naturally want to find
the path of least resistance and with
our spatial patterns the path of least
resistance is to all live together
of course rural life will always exist
and needs to exist but if you were to
have a hand to pick up and organize
every human into the most efficient
pattern possible this is what it would
look like cities don't create wealth and
wealth doesn't create cities rather
cities make wealth possible cities are
efficient and efficiency creates wealth
and so people create cities if you want
to create a website however there's no
better place than Squarespace there's a
good reason I use Squarespace for all my
websites they're beautiful designer
templates and customizable website
builder make it incredibly easy to
create something you can be proud of if
you ever have an issue they have a ward
winning customer support which I've
personally used and can say is fantastic
if you run a business a youtube channel
a podcast or anything else you want to
stand out and Squarespace helps you do
exactly that you want your first
impression account and you can start
building your first impression for 10%
off at squarespace.com slash Wendover I
wouldn't keep plugging Squarespace if I
didn't believe in it
so I highly encourage you to at least
check them out as squarespace.com slash
Wendover
you